Let's start by discussing what the keyword this is for.
This is an identifier that gets a value bound to it, much like a variable.
But instead of identifying the values explicitly in your code,
this gets bound to the correct object automatically.
Now mostly, the rules for how the interpreter determines the what
the correct binding is, resemble the rules for positional function parameters.
The differences between positional function parameters and
the keyword this are designed to support your intuition about
which object should be focal when you're invoking a method or a constructor.
There are a lot of misconceptions out there.
So, let's clear them up by going through a list of the things that
the keyword this specifically won't be bound to